and oh I got to tell you this so I was
just thinking that Jocko is kind of you
know he's like an older brother figure
but for me I a lot of people are can be
real father figures from me you know I
noticed that I'm I have such a
desperation for that energy in that
connection in my life that you know I
will latch on to people or put them in a
place where without even realizing it
that I have of that I give that up I
take you know kind of father figure Li
like type of stuff off of them and Jocko
is like that jakka willing and and he oh
this house think enough so I saw my dad
in a dream when I was in Hawaii or in
Maui sorry when I was in Maui and it was
it was really crazy because I hadn't
seen him in 20 years even in a vision
you know I know how to a dolt vision and
um and I saw him you know when I saw
mean it was crazy we were at uh it was
kind of confusing it was a dream you
know and Robert De Niro was there and
Matthew McConaughey was there and we
were in Maui and I my dad was in one
room eating at a table and Matthew
McConaughey and Robert De Niro were in
another room and my dad wanted to come
and meet Matthew McConaughey but he
didn't want to meet Robert De Niro and
so I was trying to like mediate between
the two of them
and finally my dad and Matthew
McConaughey got to meet each other which
doesn't mean anything but it was just
interesting to see my father I hadn't
seen him you know I'd seen him in
pictures and I'd seen him and just you
know imagine natan what our imagination
what his would he look
like or something but I hadn't seen him
really and he made me think that my dad
lives in Hawaii or something you know
like I was like oh is this where he's
been and it made me think well of course
this is where he's been this is where I
would be it is stunning
paya that's where I went to Pai a and I
stayed out at this place called loom
area and they don't have Ottomans there
were some moments I don't know if they
even had it's very peaceful and
beautiful little staff that works there
and there were some moments I didn't
know if people were there working or
staying or anything or there was a day
where I didn't see anyone anybody and
it's you know it's comfortable I mean
they don't have what don't I have they
don't have it's they don't they don't
have air conditioning in the rooms but I
knew that going into it and I wanted it
kind of more of a I guess bohemian
experience but they have fans and you
can get like a portable and brought in
which I finally did on the fourth day
but uh but yeah I got to see my dad man
I got to see him it was it was I just
didn't know I didn't know that he's been
in Hawaii or been him you know that he's
been there and he was healthy he was
healthier looking than I've ever seen
him in my whole life when I actually saw
him that's what's wild he was kind of
thicker he'd been eaten and his higher
his hair was darker and he was laughs
and man he was laughing and he uh and he
was a little he was she was kind of
being cool trying a little bit play it
cool IRB cool I guess I don't know I
mean he you know I mean he lives in that
world and the subconscious or in dream
war so I you know I have no idea what
his life is like there he may drive a
Corvette I don't know I didn't see you
know the parking lot or anything like
that I just saw you know just him
um and man right when I got up I've just
been on this kick rob has been trying to
stay more motivated and like when I get
when it's time to get up it's time to
get up and I need to do things and you
know I just want my life to be I want to
have more experiences in my life you
know recently I've just been realizing
like I do a lot of stuff but it's a lot
of the same things and I'm not really
having a lot of like new experiences and
so I want to have a little bit more of
that but uh but man I wish I'd I just
laid back down and tried to go right
back and see him you know wherever he
was and but it's just so funny I mean
I've slept and you know in the past 20
years I probably falling asleep and you
know 42 states and you know 15 or 20 or
30 cont you know I don't know countries
and not once did I see my father and
then BAM I'm in Maui and arias maybe
he's over there maybe you know with Dog
the Bounty Hunter do did you enjoy that
clip well you really would have enjoyed
it if he was watching on a TCL TV TCL is
America's fastest growing TV brand it's
so fast it's the Carl Lewis of
television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com